how do electric cars work they use
batteries
the most common kind are rechargeable
lithium-ion batteries as they are good
at conducting electricity but they're
expensive to produce that's one reason
why electric cars cost more than
conventional vehicles the electricity in
the batteries is delivered to the motor
inside the motor are two kinds of
magnets they're opposite forces create
motion this movement in turn causes the
wheels of the car to turn when it comes
to energy efficiency electric motors
come out on top they use 95 percent of
available energy on motion that compares
to just 30 percent in an internal
combustion engine electric motors
feature fewer components than gasoline
or diesel ones that requires less
maintenance but there is a downside
electric cars need to be recharged
regularly car makers say the batteries
can last for around 200 kilometers but
many drivers say it's more like a
hundred another problem is a shortage of
charging points filling stations on the
other hand are 10 a penny
charging points feature regular electric
sockets recharging an electric car
usually takes a few hours some newer
charging points promise to restore 80
percent of power within 30 minutes so
what does the future hold
scientists say electric cars could one
day be charged by induction simply leave
your vehicle parked and let it recharge
by itself